hey everybody let's stop what's
happening it's Anna Mac here for animal
program welcome to another episode of
Rand cafe veer and cafe oh it is 47
already which is just nuts but it's
always such a fun time recon turn off
your crazy notifications it's always on
time hang out these cool peeps here and
today we're gonna be actually talking
about what type of new anime you would
want to create if you had the chance to
create one and as part of this we're
going to include two finalists from our
writing contest that we had on our
discord server and imap4 discord check
it out link in the description we had a
bunch of entries of what people would
what kind of anime they would create if
they had a chance like a one-page
two-page sort of set up for an anime and
so we have the best to the top two that
were picked by other people such not
myself and we're gonna be reading them
at some point during the Strand cafe and
then all of us together will decide
which one we prefer and that one will be
the winner of the contest both of the
finalists are fantasy so I see
interesting it is going to be
interesting but I also want to hear from
you guys obviously the guests with me
here today and also from people in the
chat if you had the chance to create an
anime what would you create and why and
let's make it good everybody yeah yeah
by the way with me today soul maka what
up yo everyone so like so kind of
showing his face it's blurry as [ __ ]
which is still good because it's usually
always me showing my face it's the spot
I won't last time I will next time I
promise is that bad as that still really
blurred well it's the same old soul that
I remember meeting back in town I can I
can hear some somewhere
okay okay I'm I was hearing some
feedback okay so we gots all linked to
his new channels in the description you
just started it we also got the anime
dude and I have to add his link in the
description right now actually because I
forgot okay and I'm dude I'm working on
that now but until then introduce
yourself and say what's up hey there guy
[Music]
sweet sweet to the point we all anime
recon the guy what up my boys is gonna
be fun today yeah you already know what
anime I want to make oh yeah also back
with us again after last week is now a
god of what's of Gnawa hello everyone
hello think of her having me again
pleasure to have you and is that
everyone everybody is that everyone okay
cool
so yeah that's us guys yo your crew here
and I've updated links in the
description to everyone's channel
everyone should be in there now our boy
anime do decade Jordan our boy anime
recon now agarra and soul maka so yes
now we should be good now it should be
good and now let me actually look at the
chat such an in the meantime I don't
know who wants to start
who wants to start in terms of I already
have a bunch of ideas for what kind of
anime I would one of me he's a horse
lighting on the chat and then I'll see
when I see some cool ideas in the chat
I'll bring it up well let me know who
wants to start about one enemy that you
always wanted to make if you had the
chance
are we doing like original series or
just things we'd like to see made into
an anime original original original on
your mind
alright someone else go first then
I was gonna say yeah change
one-two-three and vampire Judique I
should definitely get enemies but yeah I
always thought it would be really cool
if they made an anime series all based
on YouTube like just had an anime about
youtubers and YouTube maybe you have
like your little protagonist you know
who's not doing that well
and then everyone calls them crap you
know and then he winds up being the most
viral or whatever you know I thought
that'd be really cool cool actually
Hiro okay cuz what I like that idea
because it would be like you know you
would have you know the villain like
someone like Jake Paul right like he's
he's getting all this attention by just
like clique baiting and doing all this
shady stuff but then it's like Jake Paul
you realize later days just like it's
like conspiracy and he's just a pawn in
someone else's game to make money and
take control of the Internet and
brainwash young people with dabbing and
[ __ ] yeah exactly and then you know you
got like your protagonist guy and
everyone's saying that he can't do it
and this will inspire little people to
on the internet they'll be like I can be
like this guy I can be viral to in a
good way it's positive yes I like was
that touching of anyone so what you want
in this series is basically Joey the
anime man to be in there and animate it
into a character so that he can inspire
people is that what she's trying to say
no not I want to like something
different you know what I mean you don't
want the anime to be based off anime
creators you want it to be someone big
so you need someone like someone
probably like Ethan Anila against like
Logan Paul like that kind of mass you
know what I mean where they're kind of
hitting all spectrums good let's be
honest we're kind of nicked cut in like
this small frame you know what I mean
towards these guys can kind of hit kind
of all kind of spectrum of audience like
everybody watches h3h3 productions
pretty much of all you know and I mean
I definitely do but you know who I want
to also see in there I mean he go I want
to see that type of character in there
too just hilarious dude who does parkour
oh by the way Jonathan SXF interesting
is like YouTube shown an anime where
your subscriber count is your power
level yeah pretty much some of us here
are over 9000 is the young the onion is
just Cronus cool man cool I like Crohn's
the strongest human so yeah he is my
youngest
I guess we can say soul is that Yamcha
level and soon he will progress into
Crillon I might even be blown I might be
our OB right now that means that I'm a
big dog here right now but then I gotta
like you know look up to get go can Anna
my man and Aki Dearest then like misty
they're like yeah above me right they're
like super saiyan blue to my regular
super saiyan yes yeah but you can't you
can't really see don't do that to
yourself do not do that to your slippers
are gonna overwork yourself and you're
gonna judge yourself don't do that you
guys are all at the same level you guys
are all friends and all in the nick
group we're all together this I know
right for the anime there has to be
there has to be drama there has to be
self-loathing and a crybaby protagonist
and [ __ ] so she's too nice for this
place really okay if you're talking like
Krang to like cream of the crop okay in
my in my particular opinion of you I
would definitely say um when it comes to
anime definitely Joey Aki and misty are
on top of the mountain and yes we all
are kind of crawling our way up there
but you know Misty's my father
[Laughter]
like misty there's nothing wrong with
leaving a few corpses on your way to the
top I mean that's what YouTube is you
kind of everyone is kind of yeah digging
with their nails on this freaking
Mountain yes it's a Hunger Games but on
YouTube idea Hunger Games anime series
that's good there you go oh by the way
anger Ln in the chat says do a dragon
ball super wid funny fact I just
finished recording a dragon ball super
vid right before this Grand Cafe started
I still have to edit the vocal the audio
but I just finished recording it so yeah
that's coming boys we've probably not
day or two also makkal not isn't a shot
what up my boy Mac lamb and scene walk
because it usually works at this time
now but he's in the China he says he
wants to see an anime where we live in
an alternate timeline where gas ran dry
in deities and now we use the tears of
kittens to fuel our world well I saw a
rigid as a dog person I don't hate this
idea what about you guys genius is very
unique concept Miyazaki cat yeah I just
love that me with so it's so catchy hey
guys the beauty of anime recon is that
he can laugh at himself and has a good
sense of humor which is very important
so yeah kudos to him Grima quants to see
an i dubs content cop anime I would
watch that I would watch that 100% Luna
wants to see an anime of the anime up
for discord yes I agree
that would we've had drama there we have
troll raids we've had everything yeah
technical difficulties all that stuff
would be make for a great anime but who
is going next among our crew Thank You
na wa for your insightful youtube idea
and i think it would be cool because you
could explore a lot of modern societies
kind of social
choose through that sort of idea that
you know popularity is what counts and
you know being mainstream and popular is
what makes you stronger so I am like you
know this desire to be liked and popular
I think there's a lot to excel over
there so even though we joke I think it
is a cool idea
yeah well supposed to go huh I guess
I'll go next okay yeah I've always been
uh I've always been a big fan of sports
anime hasn't happened yet
I would love this yeah see an anime
based off of eSports with how those have
become a big thing in recent years just
competitive gaming and the way anime
explores new concepts I think they could
really do so much with that I don't like
how I thought have any of you guys seen
gamers yes I have I have no first
episode it was kind of misleading a
little bit and it doesn't necessarily
have to be like a comedy harem type show
but in the first show they made it look
like it was going to be about eSports
and competitive gaming and so I was a
little disappointed when it wasn't but I
think that would be a great concept in
general I could see that done I could
see that done yeah it actually works and
you could do a lot of different yeah I
think add step to it too even if you
wanted by the way I'm seeing a lot of
like stuff in the comments like a rocket
League anime a black widow anime stuff
like that but like I said guys we're
doing original like stuff you came up
with not like game out of tations
Assassin's Creed stuff like that
Grbac yeah yeah so let me know some
original ideas guys and you know
describe it a bit for me also miles says
October 21st the first Code Geass movie
is that the in theaters in Japan yes it
is that's gonna be exciting are we gonna
see new scenes are we gonna get any news
about the sequel at the end which
sometimes happens at the end of anime
movies in Japan historically we'll see
I'm looking forward
that it's almost out of time so it's
very cool I've got an idea
yes recon recon I've been waiting for
this higher more anything but I don't
know if it's that good but maybe an
anime where the main character can read
people's thoughts and minds for the main
character can yes that he has the power
to read people's thoughts and minds and
how do you how do you say not a harem
anime he can leave people spots and was
it linked enough no but I said it so I
understand but then how is it an itchy
harem that's why I said it's not a harem
well how can you suggest that if it's
not an action harem unconfuse so you're
saying am i only supposed to suggest any
harem series yes it's your stick when
it's just thick alright
I want more harem anime where the main
character ain't no [ __ ] I'll agree to
that I'm not a fan of crybaby yeah
exactly
I'm currently getting tired of the main
character always you know [ __ ] afraid
of girls and every time he gets touched
he just backs them off and nosebleeds
and [ __ ] I want an main character with a
serious skirt a guest who is not afraid
of girls he's not afraid of fights and
[ __ ] like that and when the girls like
yes come at me ladies I want you all it
sounds like scold oh he's almost [ __ ]
school days man no like one thing you
guys know that el deca seven is getting
like trilogy movie and then a new
material as well well I personally
didn't like it I got seven because it
has a stupid crybaby protagonist named
Renton and also the pacing I thought was
bad and like the cool characters that I
wanted to know more about I didn't
because it was all focused on rent and
being a crybaby but a lot of people like
man you don't get it he's supposed to be
a crybaby oh that's
it's like no okay just because it's the
early stages of the anime doesn't mean
that he has to be a crybaby look at
Luffy look at other protagonists they're
not crybabies like even Edden I love
Aaron because yeah sometimes he cries
but usually he's like I'm destroy all
the Titans like that's the kind of [ __ ]
I want like I want someone who's driven
it was actually motivated who's actually
gonna inspire me to be driven and
motivated that's always like oh no I
have responsibilities like it works in
Evangelion because Evangelion has such a
deeper philosophical underpinning so
even though Shinji is a crybaby it's
like there's a lot there going on there
but when you have like a simple you know
Shonen with a protagonist being a
crybaby
personally I don't relate to it at all I
know Seoul disagrees because he's a
crybaby now I like I like to you know
someone I did like it for exactly I
don't find any problem with the pacing
cuz the slow parts were explaining other
aspects of the show like the disease
when he found that guy with a woman and
you know she's she looks like she's in
some kind of weird kind of dreamlike
coma state and it's that disease that
they're talking about that his sister
ended up getting him stuff yeah I mean
so you know it helped explain other
aspects so I didn't really see is a
pacing issue as such you know what the
hell happened to Erica where he becomes
her appearance becomes completely weird
like what was even what what is that oh
when she got absorbed into the plant
thing yeah what the [ __ ] was that well
she's a thing innit she's like the alien
race so basically she's kind of like
merged with the source and then that's
what was changing her to look more alien
like and that's why after at the end she
went that full like weird green with the
wings and yeah I mean so yeah and I'm
like I didn't get all of her appearance
get weird and way less way less kawaii
mind you and I was not a fan of the less
kawaii the cat gamer please we need a
panama-based around llama
no no there is actually um their alpacas
I think though different they are
different there's an anime there is an
anime with animals and llamas and stuff
it's actually pretty funny it's a comedy
what's it called I forgot it probably
has like ten Japanese words as the name
so no no it's called something something
cafe it's called something I think cafe
Oh PO love it it's about a polar bear
who's running a cafe and all these
animals come and over there and it's
pretty funny
I simply Rose would enjoy that she is a
big fan of alpacas and then we call it
llamas and then she gets upset but she's
another youtuber by the way if she lives
in Korea though now so she hasn't been
able to be an Ren cafe due to timezone
craziness but la Bora bong had an idea
of an anime by the end the characters
are know that they're in an anime and
they're trying to fight against the
creator in order to be stopped being
controlled kind of reminds me of
recreate errs but different I like the
idea that's a very good concept I like
that so come on Seoul by the way you owe
us an anime idea as well and so do I
like recon I do want you to think of I
don't know if maybe not on the spot but
by the end of this finger thing I want
you to think about the ultimate Aichi
harem anime you've seen it so many so I
want you to think of the ultimate one
and to share it with us what you as the
expert would be the ultimate the perfect
perfect the final form of a petty harem
anime it's a true challenge it's a true
challenge towards the harem King so why
not do it okay I was already perfect
can't get any better
well it
is already perfect don't start a war
oh you just reminded me um did you hear
about uh Sao actually hit number one on
DVD and blu-ray sales for their movie
yeah yeah and they're coming out with
some more episodes as well the world is
full of recons
I'm the only Rika shocking ain't no
other recon me than your boy recon but
that doesn't make sense
I have friends that are into it so I
understand
I know it's people they're better into
it
I suppose so do you have an idea you
read a lot of manga so in that sense I
mean for me I really like four months
tragedy stories no not necessarily that
they have to die but you know they have
to overcome some kind of hardship you
want to get over so I don't know mine
probably for actions sake I don't know
it might be like the soy dam dam working
on the continent in the visual novel I
guess which is like demons and angels
who's walking on in hell between the
demons then an Angels getting involved
because they can sense that you know
they're gonna try and take over like the
earth and stuff they're gonna try
breakout and take over half and it's one
well and what I've seen a lot of anti
would that exam exactly well there is
there is aspects of that so play the
game what's his mate no yeah no and then
like the guy you stuck in the middle
basically in the past life he had got
into a kind of like contract with one of
the devils and so in his new life now
he's still bound by that and so there
they're often well that sounds really
interesting that's good so yeah it
definitely follows in a tradition where
it would be like appeal to existing fans
of anime like Inuyasha and so so forth
and then it's all about the execution
like how do you make it interesting how
you make the characters appealing and
stuff like that by a good work soul I
also had a anime god own greatness
saying an anime where people make animal
hybrids we have some of that of course
in Full Metal Alchemist with the cámaras
we have some of that in one piece with
the zone devil fruit right so there is
stuff like that but I like the concept
I got good I'm gonna watch more yaoi
harem side I have a good idea
by the way enemy dude you're very quiet
now I don't know what's happening you
need to yeah Jordan speak up no you were
fine and initially and then your mic
went quiet to do something what you know
is in the background lord artorias wants
to see Darth Vader in a hentai with hot
girls all for one from my hero academia
in a handout that's good may I share my
idea I'm like do you already have the
ultimate harem yes I do trust me I want
it to be ultimate but um I wanted to say
my idea and I've talked about this
before but the idea I want to see as
someone who studied political philosophy
is an anime where a student who loves
philosophy has to after school can't
find a job because no one gives a [ __ ]
of a philosophy of course everyone's all
like an engineering and stuff like that
his family disowned him because he's not
a productive member of society he
becomes a meat but then I'm insane
millionaire or billionaire an eccentric
billionaire decides to create a
university focused completely on
philosophy and he has a dislike
test thing that you can take if you want
to join a school the best people get
accepted and this guy our main
protagonist take the test and is
accepted so they go into this university
however it's built in a very remote area
it's like in the middle of nowhere in
the mountains and all these students
come from all over the world and they
basically have all these clubs in the
school based on like different
philosophies so like you have to play it
all the people who love Plato are on the
roof they'll hang out on the roof
because that's you know he has the whole
allegory of the cave where the true
philosopher goes out of the cave and up
into the sunlight and that not
understands the truth then you have you
know the Marxists who are all about you
know like the popular revolt against the
elitists that you have aristotle who
believed in the political animals so you
know they have that kind of mindset and
then I what I would do is I would have
them kind of like yugioh style duels
where they would have like a dual rank
stadium where they would face off their
different philosophies and the
philosophies would personify something
from the things so for example a Marxist
they could create like an angry mob of
revolutionaries to fight and then the
heirs aristotle people they could create
the political animal like a huge beast
that fights against the other guys right
so it's like a yugioh philosophy
showdown yeah well my mind yeah I think
you should be a director why don't you
go to a studio and tell them your idea
in the minute and let them have and let
them make it into an anime cuz that's
something good I'm going to go to Japan
and just scream in English but no I like
the concept because obviously I love
philosophy and also it would be a way to
actually learn about different
philosophies and stuff in a way that's
hopefully fun so yeah I think that would
be a cool high school anime idea but
like or not high school like college
whatever but like just you
sexy sexy stuff already I'm ready for
mine the old hold on hold I just wanna
add another thing the president of the
Aristotle club would be a girl who's a
total tune better and then the main
character would make fun of her because
Aristotle thought that woman couldn't be
citizens and she would get really
butthurt about that because he's like
why are you supporting us all if he
didn't think women should be citizen
should you be like shut up [ __ ] okay
anyway I had to throw that in there okay
recon to you I'm ready
mmm so the ultimate edgy series now I
want to be made into an enemy basically
here's our thoughts so um the main
character first of all there's a virus
being spread about and it only affects
male humans so he jumps into our life
pod sounds very familiar then three
years later Tommy will go by and the
virus wipes out the entire humans only
males in the earth so he wakes back up
from the life pod and he's the only male
he walks outside and the girls have not
seen a single male for the past three
years he goes outside witnesses a horde
of females and they were like and so
what he has to do is to save humanity by
reproducing with these girls to make
more boys the end yes so you know
there's more that there's more and
there's multiple there's
I like it but yeah man why not for like
the incest thing of repopulating there
but I like it
also in girls Bravo there's a different
world like a cold siren where it's
almost all women hot women yes not new
but I mean it is the ultimate harem
fantasy isn't it yeah no I know it's I
know it's a manga I did actually I'm
almost done reading it and I'm in love
me I needed to be an animal so bad you
know but it's interesting because not
only our girls interested you know into
the guy in into the guy for like in
Uruguay it's like you understand why
because he's like the only dudes remains
the only dude so they reproduce with him
so badly because I haven't seen a guy
for three years they are the government
reproduces yeah the government the
government wants him to basically we
produce to people because obviously the
government has that need I it's it's
flawless guys
yes commodity is a precious commodity in
it you know and the women the women are
just they're just queuing up yeah me and
then like basically get them as like
they screen a minute so they're like oh
this is your ideal you know this is the
kind of woman you would go for white
personality white sir and it looks white
kind of shape you know so he's moving
hey you've got this class full of women
that are your like ideal you know we've
done the check and we've done the
background them yeah there's always my
idea on how they're gonna be reproducing
it's gonna take place in the nurse's
office I mean I will leave it to the
imagination young I want to use this
opportunity once again to read cafe okay
oh I hope you're enjoying a peace
I'm sure it's not over at all no but
snore Li a while back said that he would
be interested in an anime where the main
character can feel everything that
others feel towards him like he has a
sense for how people feel towards him
even if they don't show it which I think
could be obscene in like a high school
setting it's like certain girls just
like don't like you for no reason or
something and you're like oh why didn't
they like me and our girl does like you
but acts like she does like you like it
soon there you're a whole [ __ ] what's
going on I think that could be an
interesting idea
Anna Mack always goes back to syndra's
always knowing do you like cinder is
that much I'll a weakness for them I
don't want to like them but I do so many
people eat whatta ya want
when a girl plays hard to get yonder is
alright yonder is alright but it just
depends what type of yawn do it exactly
I like them I'll bet always a Andra and
she's she's great yeah but then you've
got your yonder is this like I don't
care what you say I like you no no but I
mean she's more not like where is our
bed oh is liked find a lot of people
saying I don't like how better yeah and
that's how I mean there's different
types of yonder s so yeah but I prefer
yon doors or the was it tartar tartar
Nadeshiko type yeah that is chic oh yeah
yeah you're like so just like a wife in
it the perfect wife type in it
shuffle have like a good kind of like
people categorize that one Brown here I
forgot her name she has like short brown
hair and they categories her as a Andre
from shuffle I forgot what her name was
I can play it's been so long since I
seen that but I just remember like her
kind of snapping at the end is the turn
to just such like a big her arm and she
couldn't take it anymore by the way guys
we albedo is officially one of my five
wife who's in my harem so I'll tell you
that right now also we had some pretty
great ideas
in the chat Casta for life would like to
see a name anime where recon is the main
character in a world where girls don't
exist no oh no that would be good yeah
there will be a dark dark anime like
wait wait so there's not gonna be any
girls that was all boys yeah but yeah
maybe towards the end as you find one
girl you know what I mean but mostly the
whole thing is your search for a gonna
find a girl where should be is a world
full of traps yeah I actually don't mind
you taking them taking traps that's how
we know that's how he finds the girl
though I wore my take itas thoughtful
from fate Apocrypha okay guys like yeah
I think I think so Landry come out to
Denton you their own like podcast go
explore these issues deeply you know
what a boy lump King said if he would
like to see an anime where weaves make a
podcast every week called triggered
cafeteria and they talk about animu for
an hour and have losers named caster
watch it is fire down she's a pastor
part Oh
so since recon and soul have both gonna
romance harem type anime should I try to
come up with one too sure good idea yeah
Franz I'd like to see an anime where the
romance isn't concluded by high school
like it's not the meet that one girl in
high school and by the end they fall in
love
I'd rather see a protagonist that's kind
of romantic I go throughout life to be
in a bunch of different relationships I
have a lot of not worked out until he
does find that one
person maybe kind of like a How I Met
Your Mother or something along those
lines but isn't that just real life at
the same time there's so many anime
where everything's focused around high
school everything's focused around
something yes finding that one true love
the first time where most people don't
go through that yep I agree with that
very strongly it's always the same thing
that's why I feel like there's a lot of
big movie studios like in Hollywood that
want to snag up a lot of these anime
titles for to make them live action's
because they realize that it's
completely fresh and new and something
that they can manipulate with you know
what I mean like make it something that
of their own Western eyes the [ __ ] out
of it already and a lot of Hollywood
ideas nowadays are just rehashing some
old ideas right exactly exactly
oh by the way Madera said that I'm
guessing she or he would like to see a
psychological I know I want a girl that
tries to overthrow the government by
manipulating the people around her so
like a female Lelouch basically how she
got she have a high power good
Shaun was asking do I have a fanfiction
that I like that I want to see animate I
don't really read much fanfiction to be
honest so no I feel like he's like
talking about something like now that he
said then I'm sitting there thinking
about is that like Hillary Clinton the
anime like a favor I don't read
fanfiction but there are a lot of good
stories over on like Royal Rodell where
there's just a a lot of anime like
stories that people pose like right in
their spare time there's some really
good ones I have like thousands and
thousands of views that would make great
anime but you know Americans have
trouble getting stuff like that adapt or
adapted I agree
I like it
well I think we have a lot of good ideas
everyone especially my philosophy idea I
definitely the philosophy yeah that was
a great manga more so than an anime yeah
yeah I feel like how I would be the
audience for a philosopher but I mean
with anime it does break some crazy
rules because you have like such niche
anime that end up taking off like food
Wars just talking about food or like you
know like random sports like oh yeah
there's the one where it's about they're
just like farmers or something what's
that one dog and scissors that's a
really stupid one I don't know dog good
scissors literally an iMac whenever you
were talking about your philosophy anime
I was thinking back to like a hawk
what's his name Hachi Munn from my teen
romantic comedy snafu he's probably the
most popular characters in anime and
he's most well-known for just the little
philosophical rants he goes on in his
head there you want to think it'd be
very popular didn't see might get
translate very well from novel format to
anime format but there are so many
people that just love that so I feel
like that could transfer over pretty
well yeah a lot of it also depends on
who is creating the anime right so it's
like a lot of it depends on the director
would you want to director yeah I don't
know I'm gonna see more from Jun Maya
like I think like someone mentioned the
chat earlier than modern anime like they
make you cry a lot more than like older
anime did and I feel like with Jun Maeda
he his music like the way he directs the
enemy like you just hear the music and
you're already like having an emotional
breakdown makkal not knows what I'm
talking about it's like you don't even
need to know the context you just use a
girl that's good
soundtracks can definitely make or break
this series definitely definitely say my
voice actors yeah that's so true the
black clover perfect example yep so my
cover clover good I've seen that yet no
I I don't know I mean to tell you the
truth it was really hard for me to get
into the story to enjoy it at all with a
protagonist having such an annoying
voice seemed like some recent polls
where it's ranked like number one and
shown in Jeff a perfect example if
you're like you know kid in the 90s with
HBO family they had this kids show
called crash box and there's a
distraction news that's a perfect
analogy was distraction news like pay
attention what's going on with this
kid's voice they also say that whenever
people make a manga or they write a
novel they're not doing so with an anime
in mind so if you guys are ready now I
will I can read
parts the two finalists we have for the
writing context which is basically
setups for an anime and then we can
judge which ones we love more the whole
thing because I have thought that we
were doing one page but there's some of
these are like two pages or more so I'm
gonna have to read just like a one page
worth otherwise we'll be here all day
but if you guys are ready for that I can
begin with the first one which is called
creation myth of Zelly Onate which is a
fantasy
sounds like let's do it alright guys so
this is skipping some of the intro about
the origins of the world and stuff like
that the divine entities that created it
but it's interesting stuff and then we
have the second era was one of darkness
and lost hope for humanity the few that
remain had to work hard every day to
survive the essence of yem gaul
scattered throughout the second cell
unit and implanted within each human
helped them but the planet had seen such
dramatic disruptions that new creatures
arose horrible hybrids whose sole
purpose was to kill everything they saw
humanity began building giant Citadel's
enclosed within massive walls many died
from the beasts assault but even more
died of exhaustion in exhaustion in hope
that their families would be safe first
our rolls rawhide the red city built
with the blood of its architects which
became the capital of the continent the
son of the king of the second age
travelled north and found not truck the
heir to wisdom
it currently has the largest library and
number of scholars and is widely
accepted to be the center of all
knowledge the king had another son who
was born with the ability to control the
essence of young Gaul and this by the
way is obviously the magical sort of
divine powers there he was the first
recorded occurrence of it he traveled
west and founded ed wake the mist
shredder which he destined to be the
first city to have a ship across the
misty sea a foggy ocean west of the
country like this is a really
interesting like up epic fantasy set up
I like it unless he's talking about the
mystique or noxious sea but if it's just
a misty sea then very fantasies many
years after King had a daughter the
first princess in the second age she was
born with an unusual skill the gift of
prophecy two religions arose during this
time the chapel of Yaga in a deck and
the Chapel of nothingness in Oakland A's
a city founded by the princess and her
husband during that time a researcher
from our ook annoyed by the sterile
attitude of the King towards new
knowledge took his experiments and his
team and founded a lodge using a mix of
science and magic a loss became the new
center of technological pioneering and
magical discoveries many other cities
were based around in the around trade in
the sea the river and the land and saw
rose more cities in the north and the
East then came the war again a mighty
earthquake shattered the range of ma of
the mountains in the north from there
poured out thousands of soldiers
catapults cavalry and demons so then we
have more talking about the different
cities and stuff like that but yes so
building up on epic
fantasy here different kingdoms war
demon soldiers natural disasters I think
it has a lot of potential guys yeah I
really like that I really like the whole
like I don't want to stay like blue
exorcist feel but that's like the kind
of feel that I get and I really like
that I really like the kind of the setup
for what's gonna be happening is that
the land has become sterile and a few
who still their work it must fight every
day with all their strength the hybrids
have over on the land and we fear an
invasion from the outside
more than ever Zaillian eight needs it's
a ver savior never forget the prophecy
one child she'll come so it's like a lot
of setting up for kind of the backstory
which I think in an anime would have to
be given not all at once but you know
spaced out however we're setting up for
a main protagonists who was prophesized
of to come into the world and you know
deal with a really messed up situation
really difficult challenges and see if
they can overcome so yeah as well your
thoughts I gave mine you know me to go
and goosal yeah yeah yeah you guys go
I'll go last one I really do like the
premise that they start out with how it
kind of sets that apocalyptic survivor
like I don't know feel but then
everybody is sick or not segregated but
divided into different cities to where
you're gonna have different factions a
lot of conflicts can arise from that
people making dressed for power you
bring religion into it and of course
things get even more divided I think
that definitely has a lot of potential
if done right mmm-hmm what do you think
about it soul ready ya know yeah I
really like this story I feel it's a
great story I liked how it began as well
which is a bit
you guys kind of miss but yeah I really
liked how how it's very detailed in
itself you know for everything so you
can understand fully everything was
going on so it shows that - right I
really thought about what they were
doing this story which young yeah kudos
to them I really do like it is yeah I'll
tell you definitely one of my favorites
welcome back recon any thoughts I don't
know I was waiting for I was trying to
be respectful
I didn't hear anything yeah like so
again I definitely liked it but a bit
overly long in terms of like reading the
whole thing and having us set up like I
think I was going for like a one-page
thing now the second one is also like
four pages so I'm gonna have to like
brave and it's hard to pick you know
what's important but I'll do my best and
soul have you read the full versions of
both yes I have yes yeah because by the
way thank you to soul maka Otaru Nana on
boo original Inc they helped out with
their like 10 entries and then they
sorted them and pick their favorites so
that we could have the two they like the
most featured on rank of a and I don't
know we don't know the names of
personally autumn of the names or
anybody because I don't want to be
influenced by that but the second story
is called unbounded ceasing its
selecting passages but viewing the diary
entry of that day Nia weeps serene a
mother's tears for her deceased child
before she had a constant depressed mood
never fading neighbors saw the
high-spirited mother always pondering
why a mirthful woman like her soul
should cope with loss coping but by with
laughter and remembrance of heartwarming
memories depression which contra
survive in nature and on a shared
thought among her neighbors one of
concern new pursuit perceived her
neighbors share concern and simply
smiled an obvious facade of happiness
acted for nine months
Regis had heard about this when he was
14 he wrote this memory down as a diary
entry a mother and son both viewing the
past concurrently closing his diary
Regis makes a brief sad and reflection
to me all I am is what a replacement
however we both are substitutes to each
other's laws in place to a deceased son
fortune proffered myself fortune
proffered me a mother for the deceased
one that shared thought for our
neighbors reason for it being my
mother's vibrant contagious nature one
assumes she always has immense vibrance
radiates the unbound this Lily now this
one is not giving us the set up right
away so it's kind of like through
dialogue and stuff we are getting what's
happening so it's a different strategy
again I would have liked the set up on
the first page so that we can discuss it
but Sol do you what else needs to be
mentioned about this one do you remember
just what I'm getting right now is there
is a mother who lost a child and a
protagonist who lost a mother and then
there's somehow becoming replacements
for each for that loss yeah it's more I
would say it's more psychological kind
of story because it's more you know
you're covering their Forks and you know
their feelings and how they perceive the
world in the situation they're in rather
than it being like you know a battle
Shonen or something like that you know
where it's just you seen day to day
events yo and this is more you're in
their heads of the characters kind of
thing which is do you remember what the
actual kind of setup for the enemy is
like the world and stuff because I'm
trying to sort the notes kind of starts
no it just kind of starts with you know
a father that was grieving and he was
thankful day
got a new son Regis and that's that's
pretty much where the story starts and
then that I think that bit you read
probably about the second paragraph down
so this is right near the beginning
anyway yeah it just kind of just starts
you know but what is what is the story
then there's a king involved here is
king he wants you to simplify and tell
him the story I can't exactly do though
I know we don't really understand much
about the setting but I do like how much
emphasis or emphasis they put on it seem
like they're just seem like they put a
lot of detail into trying to
characterize everybody flesh out the
characters more so than the setting in
this world around them yeah it's just
yet it's just very character focus it's
not really a well I'm seeing a king here
so is the father a king and the son was
like a replacement for his successor
well the thing is like like I said this
should have been these should've been
like a one-page sort of setups for an
anime but the entries that I have here
too long for me to read this one right
now is four pages I can't read four
pages it'll take an hour and yeah oh
yeah we just yeah we just his a prince
and he is the one that was that came by
but yeah he's the one you got to talk to
quite some it actually sounds amazing I
really like that especially when you got
like that kind of tragedy involved and
anybody can sit there and like co-relate
with like parents and stuff like that
that could work for anything for a lot
of different genres that's a really good
idea yeah and it's really interesting
because in terms of the writing style as
well the two are
very different they're both fantasy so
with the one psychological one still has
like like a king element you know
inheriting a fantastical Kingdom all
that stuff like the first one however
the first one begins with a huge setup
of like the world kind of world building
and Ameri yeah the second one goes right
into the psychological issues of the
characters so it's a lot more
character-driven and slowly through
dialogue explains what is happening and
sets of the world so two very different
approaches so very interesting I think
for both be that I would like like I
said have seen a more one page to the
point set up rather than going into the
story as if it were a book or that's you
know beginning but yeah I do like both
do you any of you have a preference you
you wouldn't mind sharing the first
story again would you because I must it
yes I would because it's gonna take 12
so then we can you can sit this one out
well personally I you can you can't
really go wrong between a plot driven
show compared to a character driven show
I think I prefer character driven a
little bit more but as far as a deadpan
temptations go I think the one that does
less describing of the setting gives a
little bit more freedom to the creators
so it all just kind of pens on who you
have make it if it was to be turned into
an anime whereas I don't know the one
that's very descriptive the surroundings
could also be done well but you're gonna
have a lot less freedom you're just
gonna be kind of trying to create the
world that they describe yeah like I
said it's very difficult actually to be
honest with you because of the fact that
they're so different so yeah like you
said there's thing in the first one but
there's not much about the characters
like we set up that there's going to be
a princess and that a child has been
prophesized to come and save the world
but we don't know much about them as
people which is okay because
set up the second one goes right into
the characters told even though it's a
fantastical setting we learn more about
the characters first and then we go into
offense so the second one I think works
better as a actual book like how a book
would happen because in a book you know
maybe before with larger rings and stuff
you would do a lot of exposition right
away but nowadays you would go into
stuff like dialogue in characters and
then slowly bring out the world first
one it's kind of like brings you the
world right away and then you know as a
set up so it works kind of better as a
set up a very difficult decision soul
mm-hmm which do you prefer personally me
personally I don't know fur up Ferdie I
do prefer the the first one the first
one you read I do prefer that one the
one who builds the world more yeah yeah
yeah with the world building yeah I do I
do prefer that it feels like a more
detailed story I do appreciate the the
unbounded one you know the moral
character detailed story but it feels
like it would be just a lot smaller
whereas the other one feels like it
would be something more bigger and sound
more like long-running more like
monumental higher stakes and stuff like
that but you know simple stories can
work really well as well look at coin
oak Itachi you know so yeah yeah it's
like a epic fantasy which could have a
huge cast of characters kind of like
Game of Thrones versus German
psychological approach and both can be
really really good
and have been you know done really well
in the past right hmm okay so you'll do
that one you you vote for that one my
camera mic no I can vote from what you
guys have been saying I think I'm good
conscious content anime dude yeah it's
tough I think I'm gonna have to go with
the first one as well because well I'm
huge on characters and I think
characters can definitely make or break
a show possibly even
more so than the setting can i I'm more
of a fan of shows that introduce a
decent setting and then you get to know
the characters over time rather than
trying to say everything about a
character and try to make somebody
understand them all at the very
beginning I don't know it's kind of like
soul said it has that potential to be a
long-running show that with a bigger
more more complicated world a lot more
detail but it just all kind of depends
on how they have it go about it on
either one of them I don't know I think
I'm gonna go with the first one okay yes
so I think that's a good like oh the
first one reminds me a lot of like
attack on Titan like how that's begins
it's kind of like with this whole well
then an outside threat and the second
one is more kind of like an exploration
of characters kind of something in in in
in ergo proxy maybe or Knights of
Cydonia oh it's tough Noah what do you
think um do they have like what's what's
the final conclusion to the second story
like do they have a final okay this is
all just a setup okay then I will
definitely Ono's that was intensified
there just be a setup for what could
potentially happen so we're not judging
it as a story I think that the second
one is definitely may as a short story
[Music]
as a writer of short stories I
definitely appreciate but now we're just
looking at it in terms of how it would
make an anime yes yes I think it was
like easier I guess for me for the first
one it's kind of an imaginary conclusion
in my head and with the second one it's
like you guys are kind of saying is more
of like an outside threat versus you
know character build-up but oh this is
really hard I I guess I'm gonna have to
honestly go with the first one only
because I truly feel that you can fit
that
in any genre and any studio could work
with that
so the one that does the world-building
exactly yes yeah I think that I have to
agree as a anime setup that I definitely
have to go with that one for the
purposes of what we're doing here
however definitely do appreciate the
other one as a short story that has a
lot of potential on its own it's just
that as a short story obviously we have
to see a lot more about it so it's good
that it goes with the characters but
then we want to you know the characters
need to be developed over the course or
a longer period whereas for just a setup
building the world the mythos of the
world and stuff works better so yeah
number one
the what was the title again let me get
it creation myth Azalea Nate that is our
winner congratulations
and thank you to everyone who
contributed to the writing contest it
was a pleasure reading your work I thank
you so much everyone who helped with the
contest that's the kind of cool show we
do on the discord if you want to join
ANBU help nah nah of course we had
originally helping soul maka who is here
right now with us an odd Ted who
volunteered to help as well we are
things guys good work as a writer myself
I see some good potential here guys so
good work all of you as Malcolm says
thunderous applause nice which is also
coincidentally how democracy dies I
think miles had said earlier an anime
you would like to see is an anime fan
goes to Japan to find out news about the
sequel for his favorite anime and I
think that would be actually something
like that would be cool and yes I know
about the attack on time 2099 and then
if there is news we will get you we will
inform you but I think some like that
would be cool in terms of like the
culture shock so because we have a lot
of like we
so they're now huge anime fans outside
of Japan don't speak Japanese I think it
would be interesting to see an anime
where you know a foreigner goes to Japan
kind of like on a whim
he's a huge anime nerd and then he tries
to interact with made of Japanese people
maybe Anna cafe or something and then
that creates hilarious things because
like the foreigner would have all these
stereotype beliefs about Japan and like
samurai and [ __ ] like that and that
would always cause like funny situations
whereas like so the Japanese people
they're like the main cast they would
consider him a friend but he would
always like embarrass them by his like
lack of knowledge of the language and
just like crazy outlandish things it's
like a dressing up as a samurai randomly
one day stuff like that so I think that
something that would be interesting an
anime about Kanye so Kanye can watch
Kanye is a character I would watch them
about Kanye I don't I don't I would love
that
also Lord artorias said an anime hentai
with with multiple Kusanagi from ghost
in the shell' now that I am conflicted
guys with that I'm conflicted because I
love ghost Michelle
I think MODOK was a great character but
she's a cyborg
should I be attracted to a cyborg yes
I've given this a lot of thought in the
past obviously attractive yes why not
yes I prefer whole physical body is
robotic yeah but if you see mezzo Forte
you're know the robots come work there
scene Armitage yeah I'm a teacher yeah
yeah there you go
Armitage they work yeah but the thing is
it's like cyborg is brainless things are
interesting philosophical thing is
because it's like at what point and this
is obviously ghost Michelle explores
this very question at one point does a
cyborg
stop being human altogether or at what
point does a AI become human like what
is human right so that's the questions
like if you're with someone who's full
cyborg are you with an actual human are
you with a machine you're with a machine
but you got to dig it that's has to be
your your stake those ask me what you're
into yeah you have to dig it that's not
just people out there that don't have an
answer and I'm sure it was meant as a
joke comment but it's actually very
interesting chobits was one but her on
and off switch was inside of her so that
wouldn't work only in the manga though
does that get in the way
no they do it in the anime too no but it
in the anime they can still do it they
just can't have children
okay did he say that the enemy in the
enemy yes but in the manga yes they
can't do it at all oh yeah yeah what's
the difference between a cyborg and an
Android because my boy Crillon hooked up
with Android 18 that worked out well for
me
well a cyborg is a human who got
cybernetic parts if Android 18 used to
be human that she's essentially a cyborg
yeah she's not actually an Android
Android an Android would be someone like
it like a creature created as a robot
there was not a human before like
Armitage yeah if Carolyn can find love
with Android 18 then I say go for
children so she clearly has an organic
body no but yeah you can you can make
robotic organic wounds so they do you
know there's no file McKenna featuring
ghost in the shell' they can that it's
just know that they can't reproduce so
they're in an Armitage Armitage is the
only one that can
like she's the only answer that can
reproduce cuz I'll she was built but I
know only goes to the shell there's like
reproduction in the sense of replicating
one's intelligence and consciousness but
not physically no not physically no no I
was talking about Armitage and Armitage
she is the girl the Android because it's
like the same kind of setup his ghost in
the show but they gave I love Armitage
that's really good one yeah but she's
the only one that can reproduce because
she had a really awesome like scientists
that worked on her and made her you know
she was one of the very few they could
actually reproduce yeah she said that
actually he's like like a dog that's the
interesting aspect because it's which is
the the game up because you know whole
point of troll bits is or if he loves
her yes to accept that you can have
children because he's a robot for
example and other things like other
sci-fi explore that same thing it's like
an Android or cyborg cannot have
children over I think isn't in Dragon
Ball Z isn't what happens is that 18 is
wished back to life with the human body
no no no no she's having she has the
bomb removed from her yeah there was no
I think even though they called her an
Android she was more of a cyborg because
she used to be human was transformed
yeah her brother on it yeah so I don't
believe there was any part of her that
was ever just full-on robot without any
wish being made I stopped after the Buu
saga
oh this was before the boo soccer yeah
this is not the end of self the endosome
perfect so it's been very many years I'm
here like I watched it but it's been a
long time but no I'm caught up with
super and I definitely think that
Android 18 is one of my top hottest
girls into Dragon Ball series see so
that's exactly what I'm saying it's
probably not to number two for me mm-hmm
is awesome no not on your harem I'll
soon eyes my knee my arm
no my Dragon Ball
what about Ria's Gremory sheen on your
harem as well no because I don't really
care for your Sao you have a bad taste
of we're hot they're hot women I won't
deny but I'm not I'm not like
personality-wise interested in
necessarily I feel bad yeah I do like
redheads sukoshi I do I like Colin I
like don't worry recon I feel bad form
tears several redheads I like Colin I
like what's with her name yo bro yes oh
yeah for sure um any other ideas for
anime that are not jokes in the comments
but we even though the one Anna Mac
harem with multikill was obviously a
joke we ended up talking about it for
like 20 minutes so that's like just I
gotta I gotta say that was it sparked an
interesting discussion cool it'd be a
lot more interesting to see more video
games turned into anime series I don't
know any worked out that well so say it
all depends on how it's done I've seen
so many there too just badly adapted
like they try to directly tell I feel
like everything Zelda oh well that's an
interesting one but the thing is with
something like Zelda's being so iconic
and popular so many people would
complain no matter how they made it so
many people would complain like this
isn't my Zelda this isn't my link
they're gonna keep on innovating and
doing that but what I do like is that
they still have no matter what
especially for like people they're like
truly a part of that community they
should know that they're always going to
keep the feel of you know what I mean
the old ones in there the the problem
was elder though is if they made that
anime it would mean they would have to
give him a voice that's the crappy part
all crap you know you're right
they should be something else that would
be bad that'd be awful no well now let
him speak
anime mouth wants to see an anime we're
older and cafe members former and
current have a death battle against each
other all kind of like um kind of like
mirai nikki kind of like that
that would be cool but tuned by the team
that will be interesting it's like you
have to pick up heirs so teams like
every Red Cafe member takes one fellow
radical Fame member as a partner all the
other and X only in like four hours away
so we're gonna have to team up I guess
I'll take recon no I think we should put
Knox with Rico oh [ __ ] dead Oh God that
team oh my god anime right there no
their life depends on it
da would be some breaks
alright cool the 1p screw Shonen no I
watched one piece I just started I just
started I'm an episode I think 79 so
don't give me any spoilers yah 79 yep
yeah I just started this I was making
fun of the series and then my buddy it
was like watch it and we've been
watching it crazy now no you have like
certainly you have like about hundreds
of me nine out of [ __ ] seven hundred
episodes so yeah animation is getting
better each episode it's freaking
amazing I used to not think one piece is
good then but I hadn't watched it or not
since I was a kid but then my brother
has been making some videos on it and
kind of I've been editing a helping you
and it sounds really interesting I have
to say however I'm gonna probably end up
reading the manga I'm not gonna watch
the enemy I'm just gonna
because that one says the manga is
better and there's no filler or so yeah
that probably the way to go that's what
I'm gonna start and also my brother
bought like all the manga he spent like
$400 on freaking oh cool
the only problem I have with one piece
is just I get fatigue that's it
I got fatigued with the series it went
on this is too long everything long so
it's just yeah fatigue how about an
anime will you go into your favorite
video game like sucked into your
favorite video game kind of like or so
many others have you guys seen dot hack
something work that hot dot hack sign
was like one of the original gets stuck
in a video game anime and it had way
better soundtrack and way better
characters way better story plots and
how it was build up watch dot hack sign
and like they have different series too
of like different people they got stuck
in the game like as the games progressed
so they like that hack sign pact or
something like that or some crap like
that but they have different ones so
they're really really good huh you're
like the first person I've ever heard to
say that usually people say it was
actually boring or something well that's
fun well that's because 98% of the
people that did it were 90s kids and
when they were watching it they probably
seen it on Toonami and it was probably
something a little bit too complex for
somebody at like 15 you know what I mean
definitely suddenly for somebody who is
in college from my from me watch I
believe that was for like the older
teenagers yes so definitely some cool
stuff this rank okay I think it's time
to slowly wrap that up but before we do
black critic guy says he wrote a story
about a world ruled by demons not not
that original I know and they can only
be killed by religious objects most of
which have been destroyed or the bones
of other demons he continues it follows
a demon hunter who's also a demon as he
travels the post-apocalyptic world
killing every demon in his path is this
protagonist named blade by any chance
but thank you thank you blog critic guy
I love story order sexy story - could
also easily be a just depends okay is
really used what bone of the demon is
really used do exercise succubus lee
yeah that reminds me was a blade play
yeah that's how he sure but okay guys
time to wrap it up thanks everyone in
the comments for your cool contributions
thank you to everyone who participated
in the contest and who helped around the
contest congrats to the winner who I
don't actually know who it is because I
don't know the names we'll find out on
discord join a discord link in
description leave a like if you like Ren
cafe before we go now I gotta who are
you what do you do tell the people I'm
now I gotta I do funny skits and
hilarious anime news Thank You anime
dude hey there guys and gals Jordan the
anime dude here I like to sit alone in a
dark room and overanalyze fictional
characters from chinese cartoons so go
check me out so you're you're like just
like did you bro pedantic romantic so
many other people I like it yeah I know
so market to you
hi I'm so maka I mainly focus on manga
the MoMA and be doing some animated
manga comparisons as well as some videos
introducing short manga series that
could get you into reading
I'm also on discord all the time or
hosting VC sessions yes souls always in
the voice chat organizing those keeping
the peace enlighten enlightening the
young fans about the beauty of manga and
so on and everyone's linked as I said is
in the description including seoul's new
channel and last but not least recon
please don't do you're inhaling crack
I won't do it yet what up my boys is
your boy recon and I make them I mostly
focus on top tens and everybody knows me
as the harem King yeah
that's about it yeah the harem king who
initially came up with an anime idea
that wasn't a harem it is defying
expectations people expect you know he's
original Europe it's more of a
psychological yeah it was like some kind
of psychological horror and then you
came up with a hair oh yeah but yeah
thank you guys for joining us this was
fun I love to engage with all these
crazy ideas I know I couldn't read all
the comments but I appreciate all the
comments they were contributing and we
have working on like five videos right
now me and my brother here at and I'm a
pro all four different anime including
Dragon Ball super as someone requests
that in the chat that one is recorded
right now I'm just gonna edit it tonight
hopefully gonna be out by tomorrow or
some Saturday at the latest and a bunch
of other videos as well five different
videos all about different animes so
it's gonna be quenched think there's
some attack on Titan my hero academia
and more so yeah stay tuned maybe even a
video on one piece so yeah lots of stuff
coming up within the next week or two
stay tuned thank you again for joining
me and until next time until next
Thursday when we do another anchor face
see ya space cowboys